- [Instructor] What we're
going to do in this video
is talk about the powers of the President
of the United States,
and we're going to broadly
divide them into two categories.
Formal powers are those
that are explicitly listed
in the United States Constitution.
And we're also gonna talk
about informal powers
a little bit in this video
and a lot more depth into future videos.
The formal powers are listed in Article II
of the United States Constitution,
and it starts in Section 1
where it says the executive
Power shall be vested
in a President of the
United States of America.
And this simple statement alone
has a lot of implications.
As we will see,
it is used as a justification
for many of the informal
powers of the President.
The President is the executive.
They run the government.
Congress can pass laws and set budgets.
The judicial branch can interpret laws
or declare them unconstitutional.
But the executive power is
vested in the President.
But the bulk of the powers
are listed in Section 2
and Section 3.
So let's read this together
and let's see if we can
classify these different powers
as executive, legislative,
foreign policy or military,
or judicial powers.
So Section 2 of Article II starts off with
the President shall be Commander in Chief
of the Army and Navy of the United States,
and of the Militia of the several States,
when called into the actual
Service of the United States.
So this is clearly a military power.
You have the President
of the United States
being in charge of the nation's military.
It then goes on to say
he may require the Opinion, in writing,
of the principal Officer
in each of the executive Departments,
upon any Subject relating to the Duties
of their respective Offices.
So this is clearly an executive power
or an administrative power,
where he can go to the head
of any of the executive
departments and say,
hey, I need your opinion on something,
potentially in writing.
Then it goes on to say
and he shall have Power to
grain Reprieves and Pardons
for Offenses against the United States,
except in Cases of Impeachment.
So this is a judicial power.
Grant reprieves and pardons
for federal offenses.
Then we read,
he shall have Power,
by and with the Advice
and Consent of the Senate,
to make Treaties,
provided two thirds of the
Senators present concur.
So this power to make treaties
is clearly a foreign policy power,
although it does have to
be ratified by the Senate.
And he shall nominate,
and by and with the Advice
and Consent of the Senate,
shall appoint Ambassadors,
other public Ministers and Consuls,
Judges of the Supreme Court,
and all other Officers
of the United States,
whose appointments are not
herein otherwise provided for,
and which shall be established by Law.
But the Congress may by
Law vest the Appointment
of such inferior Officers,
as they think proper,
in the President alone,
in the Courts of Law,
or in the Heads of Departments.
So all of these lines here
talked about the President's
power of appointment,
which is why I underlined
it in the executive
or the administrative color,
although it touches on appointments
that affect these other powers.
So, for example,
the appointment of ambassadors
is clearly going to have
foreign policy implications.
And judges of the Supreme Court.
This could have huge
judicial implications.
So I will underline that in blue, as well.
It then goes on to say,
and this is in relation
to the appointments
we just talked about,
the President shall have
Power to fill up all Vacancies
that may happen during
the Recess of the Senate.
Because remember, it just talked about
how the Senate has to
confirm appointments.
But the President does have the power
to fill up vacancies while
the Senate is in recess,
while they're not in session,
by granting Commissions
which shall expire at the
End of their next Session.
And then in Section 3, we read,
he, the President,
although it could be a she,
shall from time to time
give to the Congress
Information of the State of the Union,
and recommend to their
Consideration such Measures
as he or she shall judge
necessary and expedient.
He may, on extraordinary Occasions,
convene both Houses,
or either of them,
and in Case of Disagreement between them,
with Respect to the Time of Adjournment,
he may adjourn them to such
Time as he shall think proper.
So these are all ways,
these are all powers
that the President has
in the legislative process.
And then it goes back to foreign policy.
He shall receive Ambassadors
and other public ministers.
He shall take care
that the laws be faithfully executed
and shall Commission all the
Officers of the United States.
This statement,
he shall take Care that the
Laws be faithfully executed,
in conjunction with
what is sometimes known
as the Vesting Clause,
which is at the very beginning
of Article II, Section 1,
that simply states
the executive Power shall
be vested in a President
of the United States.
These two clauses combined
have been used to justify
what we will see are
called informal powers,
which we will go into much
more depth into future videos,
especially the power
of the executive order.
And so, in summary,
if we wanna look at the executive
powers of the President.
The power to take care that
laws be faithfully executed.
Nominating officials
with confirmation from the Senate.
Request written opinions of
administrative officials.
Fill administrative
vacancies during recesses.
Then you have the legislative powers.
Present info on the State of the Union.
Recommend legislation to Congress.
Convene both houses on
extraordinary occasions.
Adjourn Congress if House
and Senate cannot agree.
And can veto legislation,
although Congress can overrule
with a two-thirds vote.
And then you have the foreign
policy and military powers,
which include being the Commander-in-Chief
of the armed forces.
Making treaties,
which have to be ratified by the Senate.
Nominate ambassadors,
receive ambassadors,
and provide diplomatic
recognition to other governments.
And then finally,
the judicial powers that
we saw in Article 2.
Reprieves and pardons for federal offenses
and the power to nominate federal judges,
including US Supreme Court judges.
Now, as I touched on,
these are the formal powers,
but there's also what are
known as informal powers,
and we'll talk more about
these in other videos.
The President has a unique
role in the federal government
and in national discourse as a whole,
and because of that,
they have a lot of bargaining
and persuasion power.
Now, as we also touched on,
we have an informal power
of executive orders,
which is derived from the formal powers
to take care that laws
be faithfully executed
and the fact that the
power of the executive
is vested in the President.
You also have things
called signing statements,
which we'll do future videos on,
which is when a law
gets passed by Congress,
the President can issue a document
known as a signing statement
which interprets that law.
And as you can imagine,
that interpretation of the law
could be very, very influential.
And then you also have
executive agreements.
These are agreements
with foreign governments
that do not have to be
ratified by the US Senate.
So they're not formal treaties,
but they can be agreements
with governments.
So I will leave you there.
As you can see,
the President has many
tools at their disposal
to influence the policy-making process.
In future videos, we will
talk more about these,
especially the informal powers.